and this is a world championship match
between 2012 between Boris Gelfand from
Israel against Vishy Anand Anand was the
reigning champion and year before
Gelfand won the candidates tournament it
was it was a little bit different format
that candidates tournament good friend
of mine level Aronian was considered the
heavy favorite before the tournament but
he couldn't win it it was this matches
and then Rapids and then blitz so it was
you know it was like a knockout format
Chomsky was in it he won the first match
but then he lost the second one so
anyway Gelfand won that tournament in
the final he beat Alexander Greece shook
and went on to to win the candidates
tournament and if I'm not mistaken then
he came to the Chess Club and he gave a
lecture here the girl front is a great
player
very strong positional play and this is
just a really nice game I really like
this game this is game number seven this
is where Gelfand won their game and
grabbed the lead in the match first six
game and then draw there a lot of draws
in this match so the match ended tie
actually and they went to tie breaks
rapid and Anand won rapid portion of it
to retain his title so it was very close
match a lot of people actually had a
gaffe and deserve to win in this match
he had better positions and he was his
chance to do it but yeah it's tough
sometimes you can win it or sometimes
it's just you're so close he was very
close to win this match it's just didn't
meant to be you know because he was well
prepared as well so we have sloth
defense probably most of you know this
opening so I have three and a 3 and we
have semi Slav defense with a six six
the point is to try to play be five
point is to play be five and this is
Guildford sanitation's actually
he says he did not manage to achieve
real advantage after playing Quincy 3 or
B 3 and he's decided to play c5 in my
opinion this is the most principled way
to play in this position I played myself
because this is a chance to grab space
and try to take advantage of this a6
idea so I think this is the way to play
it for advantage of course if this
bishop was on f4 white would have been
extremely happy but you can't have
everything so we have some space here
White has space advantage again we're
looking at this game from the whites
perspective because I think elephant
played a fantastic game so Queen c2 it's
a useful move controlling the e4 square
and at the right time he wants to play
before this should be - to gain some
space as well so a nun plays b6 it's
very important to break this Queen side
with c5 pawn would be 6 to try to get
some ideas so b6 another alternative is
a 5 that leads to sharper positions like
takes c6 Bishop d3
and you know sharp position but I think
white is better - so he played b6 very
logical move and here you cannot play b4
because if you do that then after a 5
you don't have very good response
because he just puts pressure on you ok
so he took
see takes be 690 xb6 if you take back
with the Queen you're gonna run into
night a for attacking the Queen so it's
very dangerous so he has to take Bishop
b2 developing c5 another is trying to
get rid of his weak pawn and here you
gear from place
rooks e1 developing his rook and
immediately he is setting up a threat
who can see the threat here that girl
phone just set up what did he just
create with this move here huh
Bishop c5 correct answer that is the
threat example demonstrate okay for you
take take sacrifice and then you pick up
that Bishop okay
he couldn't do that right away because
in this case he takes back with the
Queen and he is protecting that Bishop
okay so he took he took with the pun
it's very important to obtain you know
this two squares to control this two
squares absolutely important remember
okay Bishop d6 in now Bishop g5
developing his activating his bishop
actually and pinning the night castle
Bishop d3 what is the threat do you see
it
Bishop takes h7 h6 Bishop H wash see
this is this could be annoying because
you can't really get out of this and if
you play a g5 that's significantly
weakened is the position so position
like this it looks like it's not a big
deal but actually it could be quite
unpleasant so if there should be seven
developing castle and now on I'll play
the move that was rather risky you know
he played the move Queen b8 the point of
this move he wants to get out of this
pin and he's not too concerned about the
capture because after take we lose the
control of the e5 square we give away a
pair of the bishops yes we do we in this
scheme but I'm not sure if we have
enough here I am Not sure you know okay
92 it says apparently White has some
attack yesh yeah but it's hard to hard
to tell you know it's not so clear so
deal from play Bishop g3
again positional move exchanging the
dark square bishop and he is aiming to
put his Knights on c5 and E 5 in some
point and you know why there's a lot of
pots on the light square so it's a good
idea to exchange the bishop okay now he
goes rook c8
now there is a pin there is a pin on a C
file I think your next move is pretty
clear what you should do
absolutely moving the coin away and
putting pressure on a six Bishop takes
g3
H takes G 3 hmm it's good question well
most of the time you're supposed to take
towards the center and here yeah you can
free up the rook but but do you really
have much because now if you go to any
end game it's not gonna be very good for
you because you're gonna be missed
missing those you know you're going away
from the center to the wing you know so
it's if you have something concrete it's
good you know but if you if you don't
then it's not so clear so this is the
right way to play the natural way to
play Queen b6 and Roxy - if you try to
go 95 then he plays Roxy 7 and exchanges
the night and you don't have much in
this position because you know Black is
very solid so he doubles up the rooks
no plan no not a problem Danny but what
do you have after that let's say you
play that two moves
what do you have you don't even have a
threat yet because the night is one of
six protecting it okay okay okay okay
like I say it's a playable move okay let
me give Hans commentary is like is
unconvincing in this position and only
weakens the pawn structure without
giving real attacking chances he is not
convinced you know he is not convinced
either same as me because okay you even
put it bishop there Quinn there you
still don't have a threat yet you're
gonna need to play a 95 one more move
and then created a by that time I will
do something already and by the way your
bishop be one Queen d3 could be just
made by simple 94 I just put a knight
there because you take I take that with
D pawn again be very careful going to
dispositions because in n games you're
gonna be worse almost any engine you
might be lost now almost any end game we
go with that structure you could be lost
because you're just very weak in the
center at the end remember central pawns
always prevail versus the wing pawns if
it's not like you know if it's static
you know if it's static the central
pawns will prevail so I like Queen c2
neat move it is supposed to double up
his rooks you cannot the same because of
yours a 6-pound see thank you very much
that's the difference why White has
advantage because of that a 6-pound is
really weak so it was 97 rook F c1 now
he played through kb8 which turn out to
be an inaccuracy black is playing
without the plan in this position it's
better for him to probably try to play
the move rook e8
to try to at least play e5 get some kind
of contra play so you played here and
now absolutely this is what girlfriend
wants to do activate his knight exchange
lunch pair of rooks and try to obtain
the control of those weak dark squares
such as d5 and E 5 again this was
probably not the best game for Anand he
just kept making inaccurate decisions he
should have swapped one pair of rooks
and OBE for something like this where he
is very slightly worse and then he goes
B should be five very slightly worse
because White has a majority on the
Queen side but instead he placed 94 now
exchange the rooks and he took back with
a bishop
well rook takes actually just loses a
pawn just lose the pawn so he takes back
to the bishop and now a strong move here
very strong and a logical move by
Gelfand let's see if you can find it
what move did he play here to get the
advantage here he made it look easy this
game this was like amazing if you just
look at this game you wouldn't think
that you just beat Anand in this in a
world championship game it looked like
just like a grandmaster playing you know
like Oh international master perhaps
just beautiful game
let's see what is the move here that
powerful move here by a amount by a big
elephant sorry a powerful move the point
of this move is controlling the C file
and threatening to play Queen c7 to come
in into his territory that's what you're
trying to do here okay g5 this book
looks very strange already but what else
he could have done here if Bishop d7
runs into a 95 and then before cementing
and remember I mentioned - he wants to
do that this is already game over
strategically block his last year no
counter play whatsoever and he will just
try to win the pawn on a6 with Queen
eight for ideas so this is strategically
lost Knight d f6 again 95 take just
clear advantage without any any country
play for black I mean look at blacks
position cannot move way anything so and
you will prepare a three before before I
have in advance so he played g5 well
when you have to play a move like g5
that means you're in big trouble cuz
that's there's no way g5 is gonna help
you in any way in this position it's not
gonna help you
the elephant comes in he sends you know
he sends that you know this is my moment
to grab the lead in the world
championship match takes White has
strategically winning position here his
rook is active his pieces are active
black pieces cannot move anywhere f6
now this is trying to stop with the
knight from coming in but this is
creating further weaknesses Bishop takes
attacking that pawn on e4 you cannot
just give up the pawn look at the
Knights now Knights are coming in 96 is
a huge threat now 96 95
now Rukh is also very active 96 again is
coming 95 92 96 rook has to move see
Bishop is trapped the check see that's
why you take with the H pawn so you have
the escape square you see that you see
that that's another reason that's
another reason for you to do that okay
you know if you're taken with the earth
pan he would have a passed pawn to roll
down where you know check check now girl
from this calculating a concrete victory
now check take
he wants to go 96 check Luke g7 to
checkmate
his opponent and he he says he was very
pleased to play a game in a style of
akeeba Rubinstein yeah yeah where he
just follow it through from beginning
until the end if Queen I just want to
demonstrate that the way do we checkmate
his check checkmate
you could you could but it doesn't
accomplish much I just take your queen
I just got no more checks yes but then
you're down rook yeah you were boy to
checkmate but the price you pay is too
much so you take that's beautiful yeah
beautiful game by Gil fun so he grabbed
a lead but it was very unfortunate
because very next game and maybe I will
show you that game next week is where he
lost very badly so he played this
beautiful masterpiece and won the next
game he lost in 20 moves it was
unbelievable it's like his his it was
just so short you know his joy you know
for that you know leading I just very
next game and I'm just won a very nice
game I mean so again match was very very
close they they traded wins the seventh
game Gelfand one eighth game Anna Nicole
eyes you know I think they had more
decisive games it was a 12 game match I
believe and then they went to the
playoffs where not one by one so but
girlfriend had some really promising
positions in that rapid games as well so
very very close for Gelfand to win and
actually become a classical world
champion but yeah it's really tough I
mean he he was it if you lose let's say
your opponent played better like this
was a very close match this was like you
know positions wise actually get on was
better so he had lot more opportunities
just couldn't put the finishing touch in
some of the games
and he was very well prepared as well
and yeah just it's very frustrating it's
tough especially if you're older and you
know it's not so easy to get to this
mattress again even now it's difficult
to qualify to Canada tournament because
all the young guys now they occupy those
positions getting fund is not in a
candidates tournament anymore and it
hasn't been in the last two of them I
think so he is not sure exactly but I
think he's probably over 45 maybe around
45 yeah they're about same ages Anand
yeah so a very interesting game by Gayle
for now we have time for a little bit of
time so I would like to set up a
position for you to try to work on and
improve your imagination okay okay
very famous position white to play and
win the problem we have here is if we
move the rook he takes our upon on
behind if we take the night the king is
trapped okay anybody
King takes b8 King c6 I take your rock
you have to take the pawn otherwise you
might even lose yes you seven still made
no I think c8 yeah then I take your pawn
okay in the back
beautiful beautiful yes now the knight
cannot move anywhere except c7 and the
King has no squares zooks r1 exactly the
German war Zhuge the bank okay well you
don't have any good moves to make now
you take and now what's the finishing
touch who knows the finishing touch here
the correct touch you may think it
doesn't matter but it does matter it is
materia let's see
can see five Allen draw um more end
games we gonna do with you next week
guys more end games as well correct you
gotta leave the door open remember you
gotta leave the door open remember that
idea okay leave the door open so they
can escape they cannot hide in the
corner okay push push and they skip and
you get in any questions yeah it's well
the good news is you're not spoiling it
yet
okay but you will if you play b6 now or
you will if you play this move now okay
because of this clever move
still mate still mate again all right
so that's why yeah that's that's the
whole point so you have to go to a six
so if you go here by accident he goes
here don't panic just do the same thing
get back to a six okay get back to a six
to do it but I am refusing to take your
rock because I want to win your pan I
know that I will get a joy if I win you
upon I am refusing to capture your rock
correct decision Bravo yes forcing him
to take now takes King takes thank you
very much
yeah that's possible it's just very
common okay all right
so another nice shot yeah okay eight
rook AAT go see Roxy seven finishing
touch
so remember that this is very famous
position I'm glad I thought of this one
because it's a it's important for you
guys to know this okay
you have any questions for me before we
finish the class today any questions
regarding the material we cover today
again it was a World Championship game
from 2012 match super close match where
Anand won on tiebreak against Boris
Gelfand so it was a very nice win for
gelfand
and perhaps next week we'll look at the
game that Han and won and equalize this
match